Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Du hast wie ich ein Buch gelesen und mir fällt auf, du hast es nicht physisch dabei, du hast nur Notizen.
Ja, denn dieses Buch ist so frisch, dass man nur das PDF uns schicken konnte. Und wir haben noch kein Rezensionsexemplar oder konnten es noch nicht im Laden kaufen. Jetzt aber, wo wir gerade das hier veröffentlichen, kann man das Buch kaufen. Es stammt von der Taz-Journalistin Ulrike Herrmann. Geld als Waffe ist der Titel. Wir haben von ihr schon das Ende des Kapitalismus gelesen. Sie ist ja eine De-Growth-Anhängerin, sagt also, wenn wir den Klimawandel wirksam bekämpfen wollen, dann müssen wir schrumpfen. Das geht nicht mit erneuerbaren Technologien nur, sondern wir müssen radikal schrumpfen. Eigentlich auf so einen Stand, wenn wir jetzt von Deutschland sprechen, der 70er Jahre, auf den müssen wir zurück. Jetzt aber ist interessanterweise in ihrem neuen Buch gar nichts davon zu lesen, denn man könnte ja auch über Geld als Waffe gegen die Klimakatastrophe nachdenken. Nein, worum es hier geht, ist Geld als Waffe. Wie wird es also künftig sein mit den geopolitischen Konflikten? Wird China angreifen? Wird Russland angreifen? Was hat Europa hier zu tun? Europa jedenfalls sehen wir hier als einen rein passiven Akteur beschrieben, der jetzt Weltgeschichte erst einmal erleidet durch die großen, starken Männer. Und wir werden viele, viele Widersprüche, so denke ich, in diesem Buch finden.
Okay, dann droht ja Schlimmes, denn ich rekapituliere, was du jetzt gesagt hast. Bei dem letzten Buch wollte sie uns in die Steinzeit zurücksparen und wir sagten, da haben wir gar keine Lust drauf. Und jetzt sagt sie, wir müssen doch Geld ausgeben für Waffen.
Ja. Also, wenn man jetzt so ein bisschen, also das finde ich ebenso interessant jetzt an diesem Buch, denn Ulrike Herrmann ist ja eine linke Journalistin, die kennen wir. Sie sitzt in Talkshows und bietet dann so rechten Positionen Paroli, die sagen, wir brauchen jetzt aber unbedingt Schuldenbremse und diese Heizungshammer, das muss mal aufhören. Und dann kommt Ulrike Herrmann und hat meist die richtigen Argumente dagegen parat, bekommt ja dafür dann auch in den sozialen Medien Applaus und auch von uns. Aber jetzt hat sie hier so ein ganzes Buch ausgearbeitet, mit dem sie sich eigentlich ganz undockt an Carlo Massalla, Sönke Neizl, die ja auch hier häufig zitiert werden. Das heißt, sie ist jetzt ganz eigentlich auch auf dieser Militär-Doktrin, versucht es jetzt aber nochmal ökonomisch zu unterfüttern, wenngleich ich auch sagen würde, das gelingt eigentlich nicht. Also das Versprechen des Titels ist das eine, ob es eingelöst wird, ist was anderes. Zumal hier wir bei aller Stringenz, die diese Erzählung an den Tag legt, die Ulrike Herrmann uns hier vorlegt, doch eigentlich mit sehr vielen Leerstellen zu tun haben, bei denen wir uns fragen müssen, was ist da los? Aber da wir hier so ein großes Reich der Spekulation betreten, ist es doch sehr typisch eigentlich für die Diskurse, die wir seit Beginn des Krieges in der Ukraine erleben.
Ja, also dann versuche ich nochmal zu retten, denn ich bin eigentlich voller Vorfreude. Immerhin haben wir hier Bücher gelesen zum Thema, wie der IWF in eine Waffe verwandelt wurde oder wie die ganze Geoökonomie plötzlich Instrumente weaponized, wie man im Englischen sagt. Und sie wird ja wohl an diese Diskurse anschließen, sodass wir unsere eigene Lektüre, Erlebnisse, die wir da bisher hatten, einfach fortentwickeln.
Ja, wir haben den Vorteil, wir sind doch in Bilder und deshalb sollten wir uns das genau vor diesem Hintergrund ansehen. Und sicherlich muss man ja immer bei einem Sachbuch sehen, inwieweit es von der Aktualität eingeholt oder heimgesucht wird. Auch da, denke ich, ist es ganz interessant. Da wir jetzt gerade einen westlichen Krieg erleben, also von USA und Israel gegen den Iran, müssen wir das natürlich auch vor dem Hintergrund lesen und diskutieren. Was heißt das eigentlich? Und möglicherweise ist diese ja eigentlich nur reagierende Stellung des Westens, die Ulrike Herrmann hier nahe legt, eine, die nicht ganz mit der Realität zusammengeht.
Also wir hören schon, du bist offensiv kritisch.
Ich sage, das ist ein ziemlich gefährliches und auch falsches Buch.
Ich täusche hier natürlich noch ein bisschen Sparingspartner fürs Vorgespräch vor, bevor ich gleich auch einsteige in die Text Exegese. Und ich denke, wir sind bereit dafür.
Wir sind bereit und wie gesagt, das ist ja also der zweite Teil des Salons jetzt hier. Wir haben schon den ersten Teil veröffentlicht. Da haben wir gesprochen über dieses herrliche Buch von Bibi. Bibi's Beauty Palace mit einer neuen Personality und haben unsere Empfehlungen gegeben. Jetzt also im zweiten Teil geht es dann nur und ausführlich um das Buch Geld als Waffe von Ulrike Herrmann. Über zwei Stunden diskutieren wir darüber. Das kann man alles hören, wenn man uns abonniert. Wie macht man das am besten?
Man geht auf die Seite neu20er.de. Da sind alle Informationen aufgeschlüsselt. Wir empfehlen euch natürlich Steady. Denn dort ist zum einen das ganze Archiv, jeder Podcast kommt als RSS-Feed. Also man kriegt eine automatische Benachrichtigung. Die Cover-Fotos zeigen euch, was wir lesen. Es gibt Kapitelmarken und alles ist vollständig. Bei Apple kann man auch buchen. Da ist nicht das ganze Archiv, aber die letzten Jahre. Und dort ist einfach ein Button-Click, aber ein bisschen teurer. Und wer schon einen Patreon-Account hat, kann den auch nutzen. Bei Patreon sind wir auch. Das sind die drei Möglichkeiten, in den Salon zu kommen.
Und wer den Salon abonniert, kann dann natürlich auch alle alten Folgen hören. Und auch schon bald unseren Live-Salon aus Frankfurt, der ja auch bevorsteht. Viel Spaß jetzt erst mal mit Ulrike Herrmann.